because i was asked and um
i thought i would come out and support
the conservative um
staying in for the next period because
i'm a real supporter not because i'm
idealistically conservative or policy
wise i support a lot of things that ed
military and the labour party are doing
but i do think that we have been in the
worst recession we've had in my lifetime
and we're coming out of it and doing
well economically in a business sense it
just makes so much sense to keep the
same incumbent
management team for the next four years
do you think chris leslie and his
colleagues would be bad for business
would you know something i believe that
business will continue anyway we're
going to carry on regardless we'd rather
have less red tape we'd rather have less
regulation we'd rather have a supportive
and and we'd rather have people who
actually talk to us and there's a better
interaction with government so that
we're a team together
but i don't think i don't know what they
would be like but i do know that the
week we left the conservatives where
we're going we'd get more of the same
which is a good thing okay you're a
businessman based here you're not a
non-dollar no i'm not what do you think
i pay the taxes this idea of taxing
non-noms
i think that we have we should do the
right thing
because
not taxing non-doms or not taxing
non-dom companies as well if you like
the argument against it is that we'd
lose money generally but we don't really
know in in the overall revenue to the
country but we don't really know if
that's true or not we don't really know
how many people would live if people are
going to do business in our country we
should we should they should be they
should pay their taxes
i would agree i would support that